hello my name is ana Moura Santos and I
can [ __ ] like a technical in unison at
least and I came here to talk about and
to share my experience of integrating
Mathematica well thank you very much for
your presentation and thank you the
organizers for this opportunity to share
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
the background so I this is not all of
the answer of who I am Who am I because
i am also researcher I'm a mathematician
and i work at this at the department of
mathematics in this institute so this is
the main building of the technical
institute in Lisbon maybe i will show
you so i will talk more about the
teaching there and for instance this is
one of the maybe I close this one so
this is a classroom so this is for
lectures and usually I'm there as and I
talked to 200 students of engineer so
this is a school for engineer different
specialities and when I teach I use a
lot of Mathematica in my teaching so
usually i teach linear algebra so you
see there so this this kind of i teach
the basics first and then i use the
basics to go to through markov chains
died at the end of linear algebra course
they are supposed to know how to know
how to calculate the steady state vector
for stochastic matrix and two out to
google page wreckage is working and I
also teach a lot of vector calculus so I
use also the visualization tools of
Mathematica so they are used to see at
the lectures so 3d graphics and to use
them to answer the quizzes I will show
you in a slides in a few slides so I
teach how to use mathematical for
instance to calculate the power of a
matrix and to see if the matrix it's
stochastic matrix at a certain point the
power of the matrix shows the steady
state vector in columns I use the
columns so if i put here some more power
they are approaching so matrix form okay
so this is a way to find steady state
bit maybe you know this and i want them
to use the mathematical to calculate
different things so but aim of my talk
it's to talk about MOOCs and I don't
know if somebody in the audience already
signed for one no only one so what is a
MOOC so the MOOC stands for massive in
the sense it's that you can sign in
forum
course so the cause then I will so
stands for massive open online course so
the less word it's for course so a
massive course means that you can sign
in free for free and is not limited so
there are thousands of participants in a
MOOC in the first looks this it's a huge
movement let's say in teaching or in
that began at 2008 with Coursera and EDX
so these are platforms that are the
front end of MIT Stanford Harvard and so
the first MOOCs were attended by
thousands of students then the open is
also in this sense that you can assess
them from everywhere well the assumption
it's that you have internet you have a
good good or atlas at least an internet
connection that works more or less then
all the contents are online so you don't
have so the media the online contents
are by means of media channels this
means that you have lectures tutorials
and and so ever by like video maybe you
are aware of MIT OpenCourseWare so this
is a kind of these videos but they are
shorter and without a no so the audience
it's online it's sitting somewhere in
the world and then the course means that
at least the courses that I'm interested
in our in stem so in science technology
engineering for engineering topics and
maths and mathematics so what this means
that you have these equation all
contents in different formats videos you
can have PDFs readings writings and you
do have demos and simulations and then
you have the evaluation so you have the
quizzes and some of the the MOOC
movement evolved and nowadays you can
have a certificate for a MOOC so if they
have very verified certificates for
people who attends the MOOCs and have
success in let's say more than sixty
percent of the quizzes so there are
local little quiz and then more general
quizzes that simulate like a final exam
or test and they are a structure is a
learning sequence most of them some some
of them are totally open all over the
year but the ones that I want to talk
about our tie in it in time so you must
sign for them at a certain date and they
are running for four weeks the little
ones the shorter and for eight weeks
let's say and I want to show you a
teaser for one of the MOOCs of at EPFL
FFL maybe you know it it's Swiss so this
is a MOOC about the introduction of
astrophysics so this is the teacher is
going to maybe I
maybe we see only the so remarked the
all the images so he is in the studio
with the chroma key and the scenarios
are now is running a simulation so this
is not the real thing this is only a
numerical simulation that then is going
to show here is the simulation of the
form of organization of galaxies and
then they have this kind of you see the
slides this is like a simulation of the
whiteboard or the blackboard then if you
so he's speaking in english and in
french sorry and the subtitles are in
English but these are special ones this
if you freeze maybe I don't do it now
but if you freeze you can go till the
moment of the video when he's saying
some words and there is a stuff be on so
this is the studio this is the epic
fails to do now is talking about the
prerequisites for the course so he's
going to talk about a MOOC for the
second year of engineering so for
physicists and engine engineers at FFL
okay so what r 0 so maybe I escaped from
here I will come back to the slides no
not sorry this is something sorry I he
is going ok thank you very much Oh
what's the problem oh yes
ok so I wanted to show you the teaser
because the videos in MOOCs are very
important and the first of all well at
my university technically Institute we
decided to go to these to join these
mooks MOOCs movement and to begin to
make some MOOCs the first ones for the
horizontal courses so this means linear
algebra vector calculus mechanical and
optics electrodynamics so
electromagnetism and so we wanted to
make stimulating contents for this kind
of books and then first of all we
analyzed the methodology and study the
kind of videos that are needed for a
MOOC so we came up with these four
categories let's say of video so you saw
a teaser that these are its commercial
it's come to us towards us and follow
our MOOC and then you have these three
kinds of videos that simulate the
introductory videos is only about all
what you are going to see on a dis book
and always going to work so you have in
a release in a week you have the release
of the video lectures and the tutorials
the simulations and then a quiz and do
you usually have like two weeks for to
complete the quiz and but there is a new
release in the second week new materials
new contents new simulations and other
kind of contents and then a quiz so you
have the expository videos is like
lectures and then you have the tutorials
/ laboratories if you have a look in the
physics in
general physics you have this kind of
remote labs or different kind of labs so
we analyzed and we did a lot of so maybe
I come first at all we characterize the
kind of videos that you can we can find
and maybe this is not so important now
and we analyzed the average shot land
for a video we saw the teaser for this
MOOC of introduction to astrophysics and
we did this every shot land analysis it
disease like in cinema so videos are a
little bit like a cinema so what kind of
shots do you do you have do we have this
kind of archive images then we have here
this kind of molecular thing and then
the titles and then the teacher yes you
have the teacher and besides it's like a
blackboard or whiteboard and something
can happen like here you have this as a
picture or you can have like the
whiteboard explanation and we conclude
that for instance in a teaser the
dynamics must be these are the
authorities for this teaser that I
showed you there there are 16 shots the
first ones are archived these little
pictures that you see and then it's
teacher teacher and then images and like
the whiteboard the whiteboard is a
digital is it a table it's like a tablet
a big one yes and this replaces the
usual whiteboard and so that you see
that the dynamics of teaser it's not bad
so this at this was a teaser for
that last two minutes and something yeah
and you must be dynamic in this kind of
teaser but not all contents are teasers
so for instance what do I need for so
presently I'm constructing a MOOC on
matrix dynamics so I want to have
lectures about stochastic matrices and
to explain from the start let's say from
not not assuming that the participants
have many knowledge about algebra of
matrices but at the end I want them to
go so the everything it's in Portuguese
because the contents will be in
Portuguese with English transcripts to
subtitles and the topics so these are
the weak topics so the first are going
to be classical models for these
transitions for Markov chains so the
classical and standard model for two
states and the construction then of more
elaborated models with three states or
more then can applied at the end to the
page ranking matrix so well I at first I
wanted to use the presentation mode the
mathematical presentation model but this
is not allowed for this kind of content
so I make everything in PowerPoint it's
the templates are in planning PowerPoint
so but in a way I want to use
many of the features of mathematic so
for instance the powerpoints are needed
because you do this kind of of slides
that Scrolls it's not allowed in this
kind of MOOCs you have only it's like
you have the the whiteboard one and then
use flip for the second so this was my
first how to say difficulty in the way
but anyway for instance this is a slide
that you can use and you have this
prepared and then in the digital table
in the tablet you fill in so you I'm
going to model these kind of standard
poodle put numbers and write equations
so this is for the writing space there
yes these below this transition matrix
but then I want of course to use demos
that are already then so I want the
participant in the student to know how
to construct code and and use the code
well maybe not all the cold but sorry
maybe I missed
okay and to end up with a demo that
where they can have these sliders
manipulate things this metal these
wonderful things that mathematical uses
and below that they can have the model
the figures and then they can have also
the calculations in below and in a MOOC
you can put this kind of contents online
and to download so if someone is
participating participating in a MOOC he
can download all the CDF so this is like
a serious yes please yes yes so this is
the difficulty for instance is yes
because and also the user can download
but he must have the CDF player in the
computer of the his individual computer
yeah so but these will be nice to to
have the mathematic inside the MOOCs so
it's what I'm want to say and I also
have for instance if we have a tutorial
video so this is like the same model but
now you have the sun shining and then
the clouds and you ask the participant
of the the student so make a long-term
long-term forth forecast for this kind
for this region and if you put some
numbers and some percentage of a sunny
day after sunny day and the
and cloudy day after a cloud day and
then you make a quiz yes and so I want
this kind of things running on a MOOC
also so if you put I think the running
simulation you can prepare it's not
working maybe not something was nerves
so I can prepare a running simulation
for helping the participant to work out
this kind of tutorial video and after
the tutorial I will put a quiz so
quizzes are very important in a MOOC for
instance here I put so this is a long
time work with Mathematica and I use
this kind of questions so these are
multiple choice or not so much because
you see the you can have a question and
then different statements and the
student must see if it's true or false
each of one so I do assessment of my
students of my own campus students with
this kind of quizzes and I want also to
use these quizzes that goes online so
the meta this is generated with one
notebook so it's code mathematical code
and then he it generates an XML that
goes online and in our LMS so in our
learning system system of the Faculty of
the University the student each student
receives the
individual quiz and they have this for
assessment and the discounts for a great
for linear algebra course or four vector
caucus so I want to use this kind of
already worked out I do I'm not sure if
now yes now it works because maybe I can
login so this is more or less the aspect
of a MOOC in a platform let's say if I
can log in yes so this is already
prototype you see we have this course
where where are the contents then the
course info it's for stuff boy and then
we have so in a MOOC you can have
discussion you can put questions and def
have the staff answering these questions
this week you can work or not it's up to
the teacher or and the student can see
the progress progress means if you put
some quizzes so you can see here the the
grades so but coming back so here for
instance so we I can embed in the MOOCs
platform this is our technique platform
I can embed this kind of quizzes so till
now the MOOCs in maths or physics have
quizzes but in one quiz the question
it's only one for everybody for these
thousands of students and hear each one
receives a different question so if you
want to make more certificate
evaluation I think this is going to work
better yes this is implemented in
Mathematica sorry you mean this this is
the browser this is a problem in the
browser this is in firefox i'm using the
firefox if you see it in Chrome or
Safari the brakes are okay yes yes and
we can have our so quizzes with
animations so here it's like a
parametric parametric function and they
hear it's multiple choice only when it's
correct and the others are not correct
this is already embedded in the platform
but it's it's still the prototype and
I'm already finished so I think MOOCs at
least by MOOCs should use many
Mathematica features so I want them to
have real-time computation simulations
these quizzes that are graded automatic
so and the short videos that I must do
with PowerPoint must also integrate when
I can make the powerpoints and then
because this is very much I go into a
studio and everything it's very
pre-prepared I must go there and I have
10 minutes to to do my talk let's say
and this is teaching speaking than the
the tablet and then the simulation and
everything must be prepared and embedded
in the
in the video so you see the more or less
the lengths of the the videos so if you
want a lecture it will be not more than
12 minutes long and for a tutorial I
mean more exercises it's seven minutes
these are more or less average numbers
and I want also that these all
simulations demos and so and etc will be
available for the participants and I
think this stimulates federal user use
of mathematical because i already did
some courses and the for instance linear
algebra of austin texas austin it's with
matlab then if you go to the plasma
physics in FFL matlab so i think it's a
time for mathematical to be integrated
in MOOCs and i think this is nice